in fried Nazis news oh [ __ ] I thought
you were joking do it again in fried
Nazis news submitted by noise noise man
yeah a restaurant has faced disturbing
and hostile customers over a switch in
their french fries who did they use that
really good fries you don't [ __ ] with
the regulars ever get McDonald's change
their frozen did ya years ago have the
Bombers fries in all the lands not even
close and like more bland really did use
less salt it's cuz Morgan Spurlock
[ __ ] it up for all of us they probably
used to use worse grease I have never
wanted McDonald's more than ever after
watching a documentary me too I'm like
[ __ ] honey go get my dogs right now why
watch the documentary I'm not even good
but then McDonald's changed all their
[ __ ] cuz that documentary so it's like
we could have had all the free
advertising that's where shitty ass
artisan sandwiches like we want that
yeah like holdy they do just own up to
what they are buying
okay here's the thing I want that but if
if you're in the mood for McDonald's
you're not looking for the artisan so it
was just a different mood nobody wants
that nobody wants the salad shakers
actually pretty good though I want Big
Mac
I want quarter pounder I want the
classic it's like it's like look it's
fast food right not [ __ ] homemade
healthy food right and it's not six
dollars a sandwich you [ __ ] like
that's why I talk about crushing your
asses okay
I like Starbucks food though it's all
microwave no they put it in a warm oven
I like a toaster oven
Starbucks is crazy price though but it's
healthier okay so this restaurant here
is in Maine and they are known for
serving up hot dogs but that recently
they have encountered disturbing and
hostile customers after they changed
their they swapped out their crinkle-cut
fries for straight-cut fries oh you
can't swap top crinkles
so they
now they have these hey that looks like
in-and-out fries actually the texture in
and out fries suck ass I love them dear
rongzi not this wrong wait wait what's
going on right now in and outside
southern Kelly alright so you have no I
am I could taste fries you're from
southern Kelly yeah yeah Santa Barbara
is part of building pound that's central
cold
I thought you grew up somewhere else
alright fine I thought you want to call
it Santa Barbara I didn't go to college
meaning out fries suck not alone in and
out fries yeah if you get them animal
style then you can have fun maybe yeah
you're on my side then yes we're both on
your side alright it's just potatoes
right it is general how can it get so
mad a potato because listen they're
delicious in the first three seconds
yeah give it to you and then after the
three seconds are up there if they're
not piping that's where you messed up
you didn't finish in the first three
seconds they were so bad there's our
board cardboard exactly I like the steak
fries the mushy fries like yeah I
[ __ ] love all fries I don't know any
fight I don't like I could mean with you
except for Burger King Burger King fries
to me I like you know I love is friggin
seasoned fries you know oh yeah fries
and pizza curly fries go wrong do the
waffle fries from jack-in-the-box know
the seasoned fries
curly fries waffle cut one Chris Kyle
Chris from told you I love fries look
good if you go to Belgium they got the
double fried ones and they're like thick
and big so I'm gonna read this Facebook
post what did the party you wanna read
it okay so this is from this the
restaurant yeah that's right
so recently within the last week we have
encountered some pretty disturbing and
hostile customers apparently very
unhappy with our straight cut french
fries while I fully understand the
crinkle cut has been a little
long-standing traditional fry of Bali's
I was forced to make an unpopular
business decision for reasons as a
business owner one must make from time
to time
the blades are ridiculously pricey and
flimsy it takes
many blames to operate the cutter and
after sinking thousands yes thousands I
chose to go with an alternative cut
there's still fresh cut daily we still
use the best potato in Maine it is still
a very expensive french fry and I
process my menus my news
oh my process - the crinkle cut is still
all the same we believe in providing the
best of what we feasibly can to our
loyal customers all that being said to
speak to my first comment of hostile
remarks from the public I just want to
say I will absolutely not tolerate being
sworn at threatened physical harm to
myself and my husband and children oh
well here at bowling friend and should
never be tolerated anywhere I apologize
to the customers whom I know would much
prefer the crinkle cut fry and have
graciously accepted or changed I
appreciate the feedback of those who
have respectfully discussed the change
we have had much support for the change
and many have been pleasantly surprised
at how much they prefer the straight cut
we thank you for your continued support
of Bali's Jim and I love our customers
and enjoy the daily interactions Thank
You Leslie if you don't [ __ ] with fast
food no but fast food carnies do Jim and
Lou who regularly go to fast food or
like a fast food establishment to get
the same kind of thing you just don't
[ __ ] with yeah that's [ __ ] what like
the back supply they'll call the cops if
you get the chicken nuggets wrong yeah
there was this customer I went in was
threatening to like physically fight to
see rage that's food carnies that's
pretty people don't have anything to
live for I guess I feel like fast food
triggers that drug [ __ ] part of your
body when you crave something you can't
get it and you have an emotional like
[ __ ] what do you call it that's like
an attachment yeah in a memory and it
becomes like this relationship so when
you know when you're [ __ ] feeling bad
you know you can always count on mold
crinkle fries and a golden head and
they're like what the [ __ ] you don't
have people I get the feeling but can
you picture a person going in there and
being like oh [ __ ] you up for choosing
straight cut fries off that sounds
pretty big I can you know why not
[ __ ] Bali's I knew right because I
know what it feels like to be hangry and
to be [ __ ] with while hangry but in
the restaurant
just cuz someone change their fries cuz
I get PMS and I get very emotional when
I can't get talking but I don't take it
out on the worker I know because you're
in control I'm talking about irrational
people irrational people gonna do what
irrational people gonna do what if Taco
Bell made cinnamon twists straight you
go to [ __ ] jail
Nicki you'd go straight to jail yes
maybe change the taste my Nicki would go
to jail better a different yeah the fat
fries taste way better so if the
cinnamon twists all sudden were a
different texture Ivey offended if they
changed that and said it's just the same
because that's what they said in the
post I'll be like what same potatoes but
the size difference makes a big
difference yeah it's much softer with
the wider front amy fries even if
there's the same potato skinny fries
waffle fries [ __ ] tater tots
crinkle-cut fries all that [ __ ]
it's all different you can use the same
potato listen but it's different
there's a reason why we you're watching
these cooking shows like Iron Chef and
[ __ ] they include texture in a taste
description right it's a texture texture
texture because you sort of taste
homemade Oh potato potato it's different
it's mucho two different cells yeah
they've got so add it's so close pretty
good it's got so out of hand that the
police department even made a Facebook
post okay they're pissed ha these
[ __ ] want to respond to any
more calls about French rights they
actually were on the side of the
citizens and they went in
they're like you [ __ ] fix this [ __ ]
we're gonna beat your [ __ ] swatted
damn dude they came in with guns and
[ __ ] like we heard that you changed the
[ __ ] fry recipe go back yeah it's
pretty crazy because like just a little
quote from this whole post from the
police department it says the post about
controlling our anger in situations
which do not rise to the level of throat
punching other humans but also about how
much I like hot dogs and french fries
that Bobby even had to say that how long
have they been in business oh oh they're
if it's like a a hundred year
family-owned restaurant and they decide
a [ __ ] change that [ __ ] this brand of
restaurant cuz they have other locations
it has been around since 1962 but this
particular family took over in 2017 Oh
so that's another thing oh there you go
got regulars that have been going
forever and then this new family comes
in and changes the fries dude any change
sucks like when Google hangs when Google
changes like the home page or whatever
something about it I'm like I get
[ __ ] violent I'm like what the [ __ ]
why oh but no when they change the
Google logo cuz that's cute no no but
when they change like what has some
interaction with the layout or the
team's Facebook Facebook or reddit dude
they just change it to this new [ __ ]
absolutely like shitty format but when
they changed myspace and it ruined it
forever yeah exactly
it never was the same never never was
the same remember when they change the
logo for Instagram yeah everyone was
like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] great
[ __ ] yeah I think I'm okay with all
the changes Instagram is made but the
one change and I'm like [ __ ] you guys is
the chronological order
why couldn't why can't they bring that
back yep I just want to see the post in
the order of when they were posted I
don't like to huncle rhythms [ __ ] up
our lives I don't like to do like you're
caught up thing cuz I'm like look let me
be a [ __ ] loser and find out for
myself
yeah exactly don't tell me I'm caught up
because then I have to go find something
else to do Instagram made a big
difference in their explore page
recently because I used to go there and
it was not relevant to anything I liked
and now I'm sitting there for hours
scrolling it's not a good thing that
they've changed it for the better but
I'm just like four hours cooking because
I'm interested in everything they're
showing me you know there's certain
restaurants that I absolutely love and
some of them are failing
and I feel like if I had a lot of money
I would buy those restaurants just to
keep it alive which ones food I bow it's
a japanese tebasaki restaurant that
one's fairly well they had like multiple
locations but they shut down like too
recently
oh dude Umami Burger shut down a bunch
of locations we [ __ ] love Umami
Burger they're all right have you been a
guerilla mall
I'm sure Shake Shack is probably better
I tried it twice and the truffle [ __ ]
that they put it because of umami I
thought I didn't like truffles but then
I actually tried real fresh truffles I
was like oh thank you that's another
place called girl ma I love it wait man
but I don't like the truffle [ __ ] anyway
I like just rare other burgers other
good food and they had good bone oh I
tried getting regular ketchup with no
truffle and they were like no sorry all
the kept drive has stolen it what they
were being pretentious what location is
that maybe it's a virgin Santa Monica
that's we it was probably that one cuz
there's a one as a bunch of ones but I
mean
[Music]